sanctions have finally come for the
kraken and man
these ones are a doozy we've covered the
case of king vs whitmer in michigan many
times last we left it the city of
detroit and the state of michigan we're
going after sydney powell and her team
of kraken wranglers for sanctions for
the cost of going through the litigation
that was manifestly ridiculous well
judge parker has come down like a hammer
on sydney powell and her entire team
they are going to have to pay for the
costs of litigation its joint and
several liability against all of sydney
powell's lawyers which means that the
defendants can get the entire amount
from any single one of the defendants
and it will be up to the defendants to
sue each other for only their portion of
the liability that's going to be fun to
watch but the coup de grace comes on the
very last page of this decision where
the judge basically refers every single
one of those attorneys to the various
states disciplinary committees basically
hinting that she wants all of them
disbarred no lawyer ever wants to find
themselves in that situation so in the
future we may never see any of those
people in court